[Music]
hot breath
it's just water
that was
caffeinated your ears was the slogan
when we first started good [__] now we
don't have a slogan that one just
doesn't make any sense
you're like what does that even mean
with it
nice
does yours have a slogan do you guys
have a slogan really an idiot's podcast
it's brilliant uh no i don't think we do
sometimes uh we have like a no we don't
have a slogan
you guys are just you i guess when you
have heat then you don't need a slogan
to try to draw people in we are the
slogan yeah
that's some intense coffee right there
man it's all for you man banjo brew
coffee all right
atlanta's finest just for you buddy
respect how's atlanta been treating you
down here i like atlanta yeah yeah it's
a gold mine down here
what do you say that for uh it's cheap
property you get a lot for it and
there's industry here
i don't think we'll be like that much
longer but
maybe for like the next few years
it's just random like you're not
supposed to have
opportunity and cheap property um right
okay like property value should go up
with opportunity go los angeles [__] is
expensive go to new york which is
expensive i mean i just bought a place
in new york
one bedroom that i'm turning it into one
bedroom it's an alcove studio with an
alcove six hundred thousand dollars
[Music]
i get a castle
out here for six hundred thousand
dollars
right
wow yeah so it's like
yeah you have music you have the music
industry out here you have film is is
rapidly growing out here you see all
these shows being filmed where you have
uh walking dead is out here like major
shows yeah
and then
it's a good comedy scene too
yeah you got definitely a lot of you
know strong comics all i'm saying is
property should be more expensive than
it is yeah
how long for the opportunity you get how
long you've been performing in atlanta
like what's kind of your connection here
i only came uh two other times
oh okay yeah the recent yeah the one
that the atlanta comedy theater
and then i did a little one-nighter
there and then um
and then now i'm doing this weekend
right here at the punchline comedy diner
well i was at the one last night right
and there was a i mean that was a good
crowd and it seemed most of them well
first they gave you a standing ovation
that was cool opening the show with a
standing ovation so it kind of takes
away from the standing o when i leave
right because it's like it's like you
gotta stand or else it was lowered your
expectation like i didn't meet
expectations if you're willing to stand
for me to go on to the stage yeah the
least you could do is stand when i leave
right
have people been doing that a lot lately
um it's weird i have been starting to
get some standing ovations and it will
be like it won't be like the whole place
i feel like you kind of milk it for the
whole place i just get off before that
because i'm too uncomfortable but like
you know like 15 people will stand up
and then if you are one of those guys
you could be like oh thank you and you
just stand and then out of sheer
awkwardness i think other people will
start to stand
uh i just get off before then um
but yeah it's happening but it's a
function
i think it's a function of like having
fans show up to your shows i think it's
very difficult to get a standing ovation
from people that do not know you even
though they find you oftentimes funnier
right because
their expectation might be lower your
fans support your funny
the most right they'll give it up etc
but they're not going to be as surprised
by your funny as a complete stranger
like some random guy who's 45 years old
in the audience that just came out yeah
this guy might be funny his expectation
is low mm-hmm yeah a lot of those guys
it seemed were from the podcast they
were yelling out podcast quotes and
everything yeah dick talk
yeah a lot of dick talk ellers yeah no
it's the best dude having a podcast is
the best it's also great because it it
you get past one of the most frustrating
parts of stand up
which is and one of my least favorite
parts to stand up which is uh
introducing an audience to your
sensibility without alienating them
so if these people already understand my
comedic sensibility where i'm going to
like you know justify some horrible [__]
and i'm going to challenge conventional
wisdom like they're already waiting for
that right right yeah you know when
you're a famous comedian like louis c.k
these type of people like the audience
is ready for these types of jokes from
you
right they're not shocked by it so when
you have some people that are aware of
that it makes it easier for you to get
into these taboo topics because you
don't need a [__] foot around it
and like risk alienating these people
yeah i'd imagine with your style you
probably have gotten some mixed
reactions developing that style oh my
god yeah girls would go they used to
throw [__] candles at me and [__]
like that like lit candles oh wow people
used to fight i got punched in the face
once on stage
have you ever been booed oh [__] yeah of
course what's uh what's your favorite
booze story i mean booze aren't even
close to us interesting like booze are
easy you could flip a boo okay you know
what i mean like that's not
like when people boo me
it doesn't
like if i'm getting booed it doesn't
count in the same way as a boo it's not
like boo
it's like boo you're bad you're not
funny it's boo
i don't
enjoy you
justifying these things that i think are
horrible
i don't mind that
because that boo is just the same as an
o it's just their way of saying i don't
agree with this i need everybody in this
room to know that i don't agree with
that sensibility a boo of just you're
not funny that's got to hurt
i don't think i've ever got one of those
but that's kind of hurt that is just
rough
i've bombed plenty of times but never to
the point where it was so offensive
never where the bombing was so
just
outright offensive to the audience that
they felt a need to make sound back
at you right like they would just rather
come up and punch you in the face is
that whatever yeah that was i was just i
was my first time ever doing a hood room
and i was just
talking [__] to one of these guys in a
crowd and he just walked up and punched
me in the face
and i threw them out and they handed me
back the microphone they're like alright
man keep doing your thing did you ever
go back yeah next week yeah that's what
you got to do man gotta do it yeah right
away it seems like you have a nice mixed
following now like last night the crowd
where's a little bit everybody there
yeah that's funny the funny that's what
club owners always say they don't know
how to say we're surprised that black
people are at your show
so
they go uh wow your audience is uh
quite uh diverse
a little urban in here tonight exactly
you know who's not a fan of that the
waitresses
yeah yeah you're like restaurants
apparently they're not tipping as much
as the white patrons apparently that
stereotype might have some truth to it
apparently apparently i can't say
allegedly according to waitresses at the
punchline comedy diner oh they just told
you that this week that's funny i always
ask the waitresses how they're doing
mm-hmm you know they taking care of you
this that the other yeah and uh they
just gave a couple eye rolls
you understand that hustle you've worked
in restaurants of course yeah you gotta
make your money man they're not getting
paid they make money on tips
but you were you were a manager right
man yeah a couple of mans two
restaurants into the ground
put two restaurants out of business
very proud of that were those both in
california no one in california then
then moved back to the city and uh just
put that one right down the drain too
what did you do
i think the restaurants are tough right
there they can be doomed already but
like i just gave
you know
i just gave suggestions that were really
bad too that didn't help
i mean with the second one that wasn't
my fault i walked into a doom situation
and
it was
i walked into doom situation and i
didn't
want to
i didn't want to like
i'd say i didn't want to i wanted to
turn around but i didn't want to put the
effort into turning around because i
didn't care right like i wanted to do
stand-up i didn't want to manage
restaurants you know it was just a job
right after college and it just opened
up and i was like all right i'll do this
i'll be the gm of a restaurant
but i didn't i wasn't like going how do
we change this how do we fix this what
should we do right
i was okay to babysit which is what
you're doing when you manage
a restaurant you're a [__] babysitter
for adults that don't want to be there
nobody wants to be there nobody wants it
like any first of all any like
yeah if you work at a restaurant you
have a dream to do something else
so nobody that's there wants to be there
so you have to
watch people that don't want to be there
and tell them what to do that don't want
to be there and they're adults so you're
you couldn't use your psychology to kind
of manipulate them at all you try but
you know what i mean but at the same
time it's like
you try to motivate them right but like
i also have a tough time motivating
people that like don't want to work
like i can motivate you if you want it
and i can say that you want it i can
make you believe in yourself like if you
want it but you don't believe in
yourself i can make you believe in
yourself and i can make you believe that
you can do something
i can't deal with laziness and like a
lack of integrity
just do a [__] job
you know like because because i just i
don't have any respect for those people
so it's like it's hard to
manage people you don't have respect for
just do the job
well i would like this podcast to become
one of the most popular in the world can
you convince me to make that happen sure
absolutely well you're already doing it
yeah yeah i got you i guess you got me
on that no but you're always doing it
every week you have the
you're committed to it it's consistent
right yeah every monday well if you want
to be the most popular world then why
why can't it
yeah
why can't it be i don't understand why
it can't be what are what are some of
your biggest goals like because i'm
saying most popular podcasts in the
world what are some of the goals you've
set up like high reaching brilliant
idiots to be the most popular podcast in
the world
uh you know and i think we're on the way
to doing that it's just
and then what basically the how i've
attached tacked anything is just okay
who is doing this the best how do i do
it better than them so you have to look
at
what you want
and then who has it and then how you can
do it better than them
so it's very simple you know so how can
you make this podcast you're
interviewing people okay who's got the
best interview podcast
you know in this field okay who is he oh
he's interviewing more famous people
than me
all right i gotta interview more famous
people he's interviewing more
interesting people than me you could
turn that off if you want to oh yeah get
rid of these sounds that would be great
no no no no no wait
we're not just a
right
there yeah
um
just analyze who's doing the thing
successfully and then be better than
that
who are some people you've been
analyzing in terms of podcasts or just
in your career all the stuff you've been
doing i mean you know for stand-up it
was
like i just looked at the game i was
like okay what do i need to do first of
all i need to get undeniably funny
that's the first thing how do i get
unannoyably funny get on stage as much
as i can so i was barking for a club
which means handing out tickets
to go to a club in exchange for stage
time so i was getting up tons of times a
week in front of real audiences very
early on in my in my career i was
probably getting up five to seven times
a week in front of real audiences early
in my career
unheard of so i had to say new york this
is in new york yeah
then i stopped working at one of those
clubs i kind of got like fired from
barking or one club closed they didn't
ask me to work at the other one so
i uh
i basically we found this other place
that was around the block and they had
shows there and
they were just kind of like free shows
asking people to come off the street and
i got involved in that club and i
started working for one of the guys
there and i we were just kind of
friendly
and i was running his shows i just found
a place to get up consistently and i
started running a couple shows there
with friends we just asked pete
strangers from the streets to come in
and um it was great because
when you have your own show you have
your own show a lot of times it might be
repeat audience
so you can't work the same jokes out
because it's the same audience so it's
good because you're practicing new jokes
but you're not getting good at anything
you know it's like you're learning a new
um like pool shot every week
it's like you're not getting really
better pool
you just kind of get marginally better
at these new jokes that you never really
get to try
but we could work on the same jokes for
months because it was a different
group of people coming in every week
so we did that
then i once i felt like i was
undeniably funny
at least funny to the point where i feel
like i could you know be on stage with
these other guys who are on stage and
how long in your career was that
a few years in i mean i mean now i would
look back and be like oh i was awful but
for the time i was able to go
you know i'm i i'm good enough to be on
the stage with these guys
and uh i was like why are they on the
stage so i started analyzing the people
i saw at all the clubs and it was like
sharat small like james smith and these
kind of comics
and um
they were all in best week ever
i noticed all the comics who are best
week ever were performing at all the
clubs christian finnegan
and i was like okay i need to get on a
show that is a weekly show
that will give me some leverage
so now because it's not just about funny
it's like
if you're as funny as all the other guys
okay you got to be funnier than them and
have something
so i got on uh guy code
and that was my weekly
now i had some leverage now i could go
to a club and be like hey i'm on a tv
show every week can i get on yeah
how do you how did you get on guy code i
uh make it sound so easy uh yeah it was
it was it was kind of there was some you
know one of the good things like knowing
what you want to do
so like i i did a new year's eve show
like one of those countdown shows for
mtv so i got into the mtv door they
really liked me
so i um had a meeting with them i was
pitching a show
which i ended up not really wanting to
do but at least like the person saw it
was interesting
uh and then
while pitching it
uh she asked me like what my thing was
and i was just like i just you know i
got a guy's perspective like i'm
unapologetically male and you know this
is how i feel and i'd like to be the
voice for
you know for uh for men nowadays and i
feel like they don't really have a voice
and all of a sudden guy code came down
the pipeline and she remembered that
meeting she's like i'd like to suggest a
guy now had i never said what i truly
want to do
maybe i would have never got that
meeting
right most people i think
put this wide umbrella this wide net but
the net is so wide it never catches
anything
and i'm saying if you say specifically
what you want to do to people when a
project comes up to specific
they'll think about you for it if you're
like i just want to be on television
nobody's remembering the meeting where
the guy goes i just want to be on
television and going okay i should put
that they will remember the meeting and
said listen i love monster trucks that's
my [__] i'm a monster truck aficionado
if a monster truck show comes on
they can be like i remember meeting this
guy who's into monster trucks you know
what i'm saying so know what you want
and then when something comes down the
line people tag you for it
there was one time you were on five
shows yeah simultaneously yeah i was a
guy at mtv for a minute so you
understand the tv game and all that
maybe you could provide some insight
into maybe first off even just how to
pitch a show what are they yeah i mean i
didn't pitch any of them you know yeah i
was just i just had a contract with mtv
and they could put me on as many things
as they wanted
and um there was a moment in in history
at mtv where i was the guy you know i
hosted
everything from a dating show to his
jobs show i was on
guy code girl code jobs that don't suck
i hosted spring break i hosted another
you know festival like i was just they
would they would just throw me on the
awards show in europe yeah yeah hosted
the emas out there in europe for like
the american syndication of it but it
was uh it was a cool time man i was just
busy as [__] and
bouncing around they put me on
everything it was
it was definitely cool yeah we're not on
the same page anymore
is that you just grew apart or an event
happened uh i think an event sparked it
but also they it was also some
frustration on both of our parts
um
you know i i
hm
i also think maybe like uh i don't want
to blame my manager but i think my
manager made some poor decisions at the
time i'm no longer with him but i think
that led to a kind of aggravated
relationship between the two of us like
he
allowed me to do a show on a competing
channel that i thought was okay to do
but it turns out it wasn't that kind of
pissed off the mtv folks
but after we already had a little bit of
a you know kind of tumultuous
relationship i didn't want to do any
more corny shows
gotcha had bad experiences with a couple
corny shows and i realized i'm not
really into that i want to do these kind
of fun interesting shows
and
they also wanted to make a show kind of
based on brilliant idiots
and
i felt that that was our entity in our
project
and they kind of felt like since they
introduced me and charlemagne that they
owned it not owned it but like we're
entitled to it creatively in some way
i was like nah fam that's not what it is
so that show ends up being uncommon
sense which is charlemagne's show oh
okay
and um
and i was asked to be on it you know but
originally those talks started with the
possibility of us doing some sort of
brilliant idiot show or is it a segment
on a show or how we how we do it and i
was just protective of it i was
you know i remember they called me it
was like hey we want you and uh
charlemagne to do
this like weekly show where you guys
have i remember they're all on the phone
it was they asked me to come for a
meeting but it snowed so we ought to
call we want you to have this weekly
show where you guys you know talk about
the pop culture things you and
charlemagne
and um
and then you maybe have a guest and then
you uh take questions from fans
now the formula for brilliant idiots is
we talk about pop culture have a guess
and then we do ask an idiot that's what
we were doing so when they said that to
me i was just on the phone and they're
waiting for me to be like oh my god
awesome guys thank you so much and i was
like well isn't that brilliant idiots
and they're like well this is a popular
format and i was like
all right cool man you know and then
like we want to call it guy code live
and i go well haven't we done the whole
guy code thing already isn't that
that's already kind of well the guide
code brand is bigger than you know
brilliant idiot's brand it absolutely
was
but
they just didn't like my lack of
enthusiasm gotcha yeah do you know how
guy code all got started because i had
billy sorel's on here are you familiar
with billy sorel how do i know that guy
oh there was a whole controversy where
he had this youtube segment that then
magically appeared as this mtv2 show
called guy code so he had a show called
guy code it wasn't called guy code but
there were like specific sketches that
were pretty much mirror image get out on
no like what there was like a whole
lawsuit and everything
get the [__] out of here i'm serious
yeah he's on wild and out now and
everything so he's like he's bad he's
been working with mtv too again but like
yeah it was it was a whole
ordeal he had to sit down with like
viacom and everything wow he sued
flyacon
but i guess i guess as the talent you
guys don't hear the behind the scenes
but it was just interesting i don't know
if you knew
god no
no i know the guy who made it uh ryan
ling and he's put me in a bunch of other
stuff and you know i continue to work
with ryan
um
i mean i'll be honest i don't think
there's any creative genius behind the
idea of
a show that just talks about what men
should do i mean
gq has been telling us to do that for
years maxim has been telling us to do
that for years i don't think
the uh
i don't think the idea is that novel
it just so happened that it was put into
a place where people really gravitated
to it yeah and you've seen similar like
the comedy central
like with the the david tells stand-up
show where you were you were talking to
comedy central you just passingly about
this
oh yeah you just appeared dave attell at
the same venue you were talking about
yeah yeah that's so funny wow yeah
you've done your research
you go deep um
yeah that's right i had a meeting with
comey comey central has never put me on
their channel
uh
and uh
you have never gotten that much love
from the stand-up comedy industry it's
very interesting
um
but uh
but yeah the uh but yeah i remember i
had a meeting with them and i was like
yeah it'd be really cool you know you
just showcased like what it's like in a
club you know and i was talking to and i
remember as i mentioned i was talking to
david tell about it yeah it'd be cool
just showcasing you know what it's like
to be in a club in new york you know and
that kind of experience
and uh when we shoot at the you know
underground this that we are like hey
that's interesting
never heard back from them
and then i just saw that show come on
comedy central and the worst part was
they didn't even ask me to be in the
[__] show right you know what i mean
i don't know if you already had that in
a pipeline or not but it's like if you
did have it in the pipeline you might as
well mention it in the meeting
so you don't look like you know you're
biting the [__] that i'm pitching you
but this hap this uh this happens all
the time
yeah why do you think you haven't been
as
i guess like a better word embraced in
the stand-up world it's it's a it's a
weird thing
i think there's a lot of maybe judge a
book by its cover with me
you know i think like people see me
they're like i maybe don't look like a
traditional goofy
weirdo stand-up guy you know i think i
kind of look like the guy who maybe
bullied these people in high school
which is why they're a stand-up in the
first place right right right so i think
that's the assumption of me because when
people see my set actually
the initial reaction is this i am this
way oh he's [__] douchey you know
[__] uh
bro frat broy you know
and then
you see my set and it's like oh [__] no
these are like good
thoughts this guy's kind of smart what's
going on oh this is not what i expected
and um
i just feel like you need to get past
that in order to maybe
to maybe see me but i've never been
really championed by the industry in
that in that regard i'm also like a 30
year old white dude that's not really
what the industry's looking for right
now if i was trans i'd be on every
[__] stand-up special in the world
that being said outside whatever makes
your life
harder in life
makes it easier for you and stand up
whatever makes it easy for you to stand
up makes your life
way harder in life
does that make sense yeah you know what
i mean yeah it's true so being six two
with a full head of hair white makes
life pretty great you know stand up i
gotta work extra hard to compete with
these people better grow a beard and put
on a flannel shirt exactly yeah i got to
fit some even that's probably played out
i got to have something else
yeah i got to be like autistic
how can he overcome this it's like
it's like funny is not about funny
anymore it's about like boxes you check
off like
and it sounds it sounds bitter but
i don't actually mind it and it it
bothered me a lot
at first because it was like uh this is
what i love and i and i i'm on stage
with these people and i know i'm funnier
than them so that's never been a
question but it's like man why why
haven't i been embraced in the same way
or given the same opportunities you know
like even for me to do montreal you know
the comedy festival yeah like for most
people to do new faces on montreal
they're a new face to comedy they
haven't done anything in the comedy
world for me to do new faces i already
had a
six-figure deal with mtv and i already
had two of my own shows that i was
hosting coming on to air and two tv
shows that i was like a major part of
that were already on air so
you know how like you hear people talk
about like uh marginalized minorities
about what they need to do in order to
get a shot you know like what barack
needed to actually overcome in order to
be present is way different than george
bush whatever like that like what i had
to do just to get new faces in montreal
was unprecedented that's impressive
nobody's been more qualified for new
faces in montreal history than me that's
got to be a fact
how many years into your career was that
i don't know
forget to be honest with you
but um
yeah but never invited back to montreal
either
very interesting there's something
there's some kind of
i don't know if it's stigma it's so
interesting it's like in order for me
the weird thing for me has always been
like give me the people not the industry
if you give me the people we're good
like i'm the guy who like
you i you gotta just test the show like
you put me on the show
and you're like all right we'll put them
on i think it's fine and then you get
the results back from when you test the
do the pilot test right they're like oh
yeah we love that guy the people love it
and then the network embraces it so my
feeling is like just get it to the
people i don't want to hear what you got
to say
network don't worry about it yeah you
guys have your opinions that's fine just
give it to the people they'll tell you
what to do have you tried to even do
like late night spots like a coney or
anything
i started preparing it a little bit and
i was so miserable in preparing it that
i just was like i don't one want to do
this two i don't see the return on
investment
you know like it's it's it's you're
investing time you're investing fun like
now it's not fun to work on these sets
i don't get to
do comedy how i normally do comedy or
speak how i want to speak on stage
and the return on investment is what
nothing
right the
i already have tv you know so like and i
already have something that brings
people to the shows
so it's like
would i do it yes would i love to do the
couch where we have the conversation
absolutely and will i eventually do it
in the future sure
but it wasn't something i felt like
would really help me now
that's what's interesting is you've done
all this television but pretty much
everybody at your show last night was
from the podcast yeah tv doesn't do the
same thing anymore
he's lost his power
yeah it's just it's not that his loss of
power but one there's just so much tv
but two there's a difference between
being on tv and being on something you
watch a guy was a lead in a sitcom
nobody comes out to show us because of
that
so the sitcom on the on ifc called
benders now it's on netflix
did one season nobody's on nobody comes
out to shows because of that
guy code
was a wildly popular show
peop these kids who watch it were a
little too young to come out to the
comedy club but when i would do colleges
there were a thousand people in the
audience it was unbelievable lines down
the [__]
campus i mean it was unbelievable when
we would do these shows
so there's a difference between just
being on tv doesn't mean people come out
to your shows you have to be on
something that people relate to and [__]
with
and the podcast is the extreme version
of that instead of me being on your tv
screen for a total of 45 seconds in one
episode of guy code
i'm in your ears
two hours a week
you know my family you know my brother
you know my my friends you know the
shitty things that are happening to me
you know the good things are happening
to me you know the girl that i'm dating
you know everything about my life i'm
one of your good friends you know more
about me than you know about most of the
people that you work with
so if i come to your city yeah you're
gonna come say what's up you already
invested all this time in my life you're
gonna not say hi when i'm here yeah
it's a different relationship with
podcasts when i speak to people listen
to podcasts i'm not speaking of fans
i'm speaking of people know me
it's a different relationship
what are some common mistakes you're
seeing comedians make because everybody
wants to generate a fan base and
everybody has their own idea of what
works but you seem to have a really
interesting and
smart view on kind of how this game
works so really any insight you have
would be greatly appreciated i don't
know man i've always searched for
leverage
and i grew up in a small family business
my parents they owned a business they
owned a dance studio but i saw the
leverage that they had you know they
owned the studio so they
my dad could take off work if he needed
to take me to a basketball game or some
[__] you know um my mom
you know they always look for leverage
in things you know my mom was immigrants
who's from scotland stopped going like
15 ends up buying property in new york
you know because of her success and like
buys a beach house but
even with the beach house and that kind
of [__] her mentality was well we could
just rent this out if we need to pay for
something
we could just rent the home here in new
york out if we need to do so like how do
you you know the second they bought the
home in new york they created an
apartment to within it to rent it out it
was constantly safety and security
so with me i'm thinking of my career all
the time okay if this [__] with mtv
stops what do i got
oh i got this podcast popular okay
that's gonna sustain me financially okay
good
now i gotta branch it off on the podcast
how do i create leverage in the world oh
can i get people to a show yeah can i
get more people to a show than than some
of these people who are on tv yeah maybe
the clubs won't recognize that at first
but once i come there
boom
so how do you have leverage in this
business these guys on social media who
frankly aren't even close to as funny as
many of my favorite comedians
have all the leverage they're making way
more money than people on tv now because
they have leverage they could say hey i
got eight million fans and i can tell
eight million people to watch this show
how much is that worth to you nbc how
much is that worth to you
netflix worth real money if you're a
really funny comedian
but you only got a thousand followers on
instagram
you can only tell a thousand people come
to your show now nbc's got to do all the
work
and getting people to come to the show
if i'm nbc
and this instagram comedian who
auditions just as well as this 1 000
follower comedian
did it's a no-brainer who i'm going to
pick
think about how much better you you are
gonna have to be for that role
if you have no leverage
in order to be chosen you gotta be
it's worth
not
telling eight million people
for free
funny
so is that your
your whole game was you want to get
undeniably funny first that's first not
everything comes from that and you're
always growing
and you were
i loved your hustle with that because
you would actually transcribe like dave
chappelle's specials you were looking at
the math yeah of comedy or do you still
take that same approach in analyzing
your sets now it's more like
the matrix now it's more like neo you
know like neil when he sees the green
[__] like that's how it is when you
watch comedy now you're just like oh i
see what he did there okay back in the
day you didn't know how to see the
matrix right so you had to write it down
and really [__] translate what is he
doing here
how is his premise and
how does okay
like i was trying to understand the
language of comedy so now i understand a
language
so it's it's less
like i don't even like watching famous
guys because i don't want them to
influence me but if i do watch it it
will just be like okay this is really
it's more to inspire me to push it
further mm-hmm you know like dave
chappelle's recent special i love the
structure of it
so now i'm thinking about with specials
it's like it's got to be more than just
an hour of jokes there's got to be some
arc yeah you know i mean it's got to be
something pulling this whole thing
together what is it so now that's how i
think about a special because of him
and you actually funded your own special
right yeah i shot my own yeah and we've
been struggling to sell it man it's a
perfect example like you would think
that that would be a no-brainer you know
i shot a sitcom
[__] comes on netflix
people see you know you go see me live
that's undeniable in terms of you know
funny
um
i've been on tv i have a podcast quarter
million subscribers you know people
listen like
you would think that with these things
it's a no-brainer compared to the people
that are getting opportunities for
specials
i could the only thing i could chalk it
up to is
i mean honestly i just i the oh i can't
i don't even understand it besides the
fact that like maybe 30-year-old white
guys aren't
cool right now
to give specialty that's the only thing
i could chalk it up to
do you think it's the structure because
isn't yours like in 15-minute chunks
which makes even better it's unique
like that's what you that's even better
like so the way i did the special was i
did five different comedy clubs in new
york and i tape the
the hour over those five clubs and then
i tape the cab rides in between so it
gives you an idea of what the night was
like this is a night in new york for
people who are comedy fans
there's
to be folklore
new york comedian so you could do 20
spots a night you could do whatever so
like this is a real inside look at what
it is to be a new york comic
and i gave you the hour special as well
and um i did this purposely because i
knew if i just did a regular special
it wouldn't it wouldn't be enough
i knew how big i had to be as a as a as
like a celebrity in order to sell a
special
right
so
and i knew i didn't have that just on
name right because i don't have any
other like box to check off like if i
you know i'm saying if i was like part
penguin and i was doing a comedy then it
would be like he's a penguin guy you
know you know you've got to check out
this penguin person's comic special or
whatever right so i knew that so i'm
like what i'll do is i'll make something
artistic as well
i'll increase the equity of this special
increase the value
right that's how i'm thinking
and um and we've been talking to people
you know we've been back and forth with
certain people and there's there's
interest in certain places and just a
certain place we're like no sorry your
name's not big enough that's that the
other
wow
what
oh i was depressed man i was like is
what's wrong am i not getting this like
it's very difficult to go on a road
crush
go in the city crush with the same
material and be like no i know this is
good material i feel proud of it and
then be rejected over and over again for
the special right because you're like
was it not good what's going on you got
to like re-watch it and be like no it's
good right yeah yeah i believe in this
kind of stuff you know
it was a very difficult time for me man
you were actually like you were
depressed like you actually
i was just down on it yeah i know down
on comedy it was down you know i was
just down on myself i thought it would
sell on a [__] day like that we were
getting no's from places i didn't even
want to sell it to like i was like yeah
you can show it to showtime but i'm not
going to give it to you know what i mean
like like i sell it to them you know man
we're going netflix or hbo that's it you
know like
and then when they were saying no i was
like what do you mean no what is it
i didn't get the chance to say no first
you know
so it was just a reality check
so what do you what do you what do you
think's missing or like what are you
trying to do
to make sure it happens like you said
you set goals and you make sure you be
specific about what you want to happen
so you want this to be released what do
you well i mean i basically decide this
and i my feel my feeling with this which
i was which what i thought was a
no-brainer is i hear i have this podcast
that has a quarter million people
listening per episode
this is my leverage this is what i can
offer a network i can bring these people
to you to watch this show
i know that you're not choosing people
for your specials based on just comedic
merit
right because
i see the specials
you know what i mean
is not to [__] on people but you know it
is what it is there's you know comedy's
not entirely subjective we know that
there's funny specials we know there's
not funny specials yeah that's how the
reality is
um i'm not saying i'm dave chappelle
dave spells you are gonna be the
greatest comedian ever i'm not saying
i'm patrice o'neill's great
greatest community but there are people
who have specials out that i know that
i'm funnier than and this is a better
special then
um
so
i i i felt like my leverage would be
okay you're giving this person a special
but he can't bring you numbers and eyes
i can offer something funnier and
numbers and i like this is a business
transaction let's treat this like
business i have people who want to see
the special
plus you have your people who like
comedy let's bring these two worlds
together
ta-da
no-brainer
some people it's a brainer i guess
for everyone so far i guess it is very
it was very difficult very difficult so
what i basically said was
look if we don't get it off if we don't
get it sold soon what i'm going to do is
release it myself
and i'll prove the product myself
i think that's what you have to do yeah
that's what i tell everybody do
everybody complains about the industry
as being so racist this that the other
just make your own movie if it's
successful everybody will want to make a
movie with you
and that is the good thing about having
the power and having numbers is that you
can do it your way now and another guy
of course your right hand man
charlemagne
has done it his way as well i mean
this guy is another rising stock what
have you learned unbelievable from
working
side by side with this guy just
unbelievable talent he's probably the
most talented person i've ever worked
with he's unbelievable relentless work
ethic and just an unbelievable talent
and um he's made me much better what i
do that's for sure you know
uh
just made me really buckle down and like
you know i'm i'm confident i speak well
enough in [__] well enough where i
can get people to believe [__] even if i
don't have anything to back it up
and
he
does that even better than i do
so what he forced me to do was
find statistics and research to back up
my claims because if we just get into a
[__] combo he's going to win
he's an unbelievable bullshitter
unbelievable nobody's better right
at just the art of like communicating a
point he just knows how to do it
and uh so what it forced me to do is get
my point and then get things that are
irrefutable to back it up and it made me
a much better communicator i'm very
grateful for him for for for forcing me
to do that he's not like something he
told me to do but it's something that
working with somebody who's that good
made me do and help you with the
business side as well
absolutely his business acumen's great i
mean he's just his strategy his good
strategy but it was just one of those
things where it's like
and the podcast made me realize this is
like if you build it and it works people
will [__] with you
you know and that's why i say to
everybody it's like and i take my own
advice like with this special i'll put
out myself prove that people [__] with
it prove that it's hot make it hot
with my fans and supporters from the
podcast and other things and then all of
a sudden the industry would be like oh
we noticed that your special's really
good uh
we would love to work with you on
another special when a week ago it was
now we're good yeah
that's how this business works they want
to be second that's why everybody keeps
complaining they go oh my god it's so
racist is that no they just don't want
to be the first one
you know empire comes out right
you always hear this [__] about it's
like oh they're not giving uh black
people opportunities in hollywood empire
comes out right
success immediately after empire comes
out they release power on stars
vh1 has this is the beat or something
like that or the beats or whatever
netflix releases another hip-hop-based
show called
oh yeah by buzz lerman
uh fx releases atlanta
literally every channel releases their
version
of a hip-hop show hip-hop music kind of
show that is what hollywood is once you
prove that it works
everybody else
wants a piece of it
so
it's not that hollywood is explicitly
racist and mean meaning they're like
like we got to keep asians out of
hollywood we got to keep whatever out of
hollywood we got to keep black we want
to hunt that's not about what it's about
it's
one they're clueless they have they're
just so detached from anything that
isn't their exact world
and two they're just not willing to risk
the money once you prove it makes money
do whatever the [__] you want the guy
who may get out jordan peele or whatever
he can make whatever he wants now
he can make whatever he wants it's a
blank check for whatever his next movie
is because he proved the product so if
no one's giving me an opportunity i'm
gonna take my own advice i'm gonna sell
the [__] product i'm gonna get all my
friends to
you know support it hopefully and tell
people about it you know go on podcasts
like this promote it do grassroots get
people to
talk about it and hopefully get some
buzz and the people themselves show that
hey there's interest in what i do and
then we have all these conv
conversations with the the you know the
uh
the networks
and then i get to remind them that they
said no the first time
and then it gives you the leverage
though i don't need you yeah you know
what i'm saying my dick's getting sucked
why should i pull my dick out of this
girl's mouth so you could suck it
that's the con that's where we're going
so now you got to prove my dick's
getting stuck and it's lovely right so
now you're coming over and you're like i
want to suck your dick and it's like all
right well what are you going to do
different
you know what i mean because i'm gonna
come with this so what are you gonna do
you know what i mean i wanted you to
suck my dick that's why i came to you
you know what i mean i came to you first
so you could suck my dick and you said
no
so now you're gonna need some extra [__]
dude what a great analogy that was
that's what this business is man
you can't be upset don't be bitter just
be better
boom oh we better be better man that's
really what it comes down to don't be
bitter be better that's what it is
that's why everybody gets all upset
about like there's a lack of opportunity
like i even hear people saying this [__]
like
oh they aren't giving you know white
guys roles anymore this that the other
like i hear people in the street people
saying [__] and it's like good good this
is what are you upset about first of all
it's good that we have diversity in in
hollywood second
it's just gonna make you better it's
gonna make you write your own project
it's gonna make you write the role that
you actually want instead of just lazily
going to any [__] audition
are you riding any uh more pilots or
anything right now
i'm kind of like off and on working on
this show
but um you sound super enthused about it
no i'm really enthused to work with work
with because we were i was working on
with whitney cummings and i think she's
just so [__] brilliant so talented
and i really like working with her on it
but
uh i'm not passionate about it to work
on it on my own as of now
i'm passionate to work with her
on it i think we could create something
really funny and really special
seems like you're good at surrounding
yourself with the right people
i'm picky yeah
you know i mean like i have a very small
circle you know i'm not really
like one of these and that's probably
why i don't get certain opportunities
the other comics get like i don't get
invites these festivals and that kind of
[__] like that because i don't really
hang out with comics that much i have my
close comic friends and um
and yeah and i'm and i'm yeah it's just
i like the people i like so if i like
you i'll [__] with you and i want to be
around you but it's very difficult for
me to be around you if i don't think
you're funny
you know what i'm saying because like
i'm going to want to help you but if i
don't think you're funny it's hard for
me to help you yeah but if i think
you're funny i'm going to force you into
[__] and i forced my buddy akash into
getting jobs when they said no to him
like i just told him to keep coming
and eventually they just buckled down
and just started paying him
you know like yeah but like if i believe
in you that's that will happen so i
believe you know
before charlemagne was charlemagne he
was just this other guy on the show with
me on guy code and then he had a morning
show the breakfast club that i never
listened to because i listened to hot 97
my whole life growing up if you're in
new york 105 1 was like this
other [__] hot 97 is what we listen to
now high 97 is trash now it's all
the breakfast club
but you know for real new yorkers we
never listened to 1051.
so it was just somebody who i saw on the
show and i gravitated to because i
thought he was truly talented
you know and that's why i want to work
with them say i feel the same way with
little duval there are plenty of people
that were on that show
that
i just don't work with regularly
and they they're really nice guys and i
think that they are
they have great talent in certain areas
but it just wasn't i didn't want to
i didn't want to create with them i
didn't have that urge
what is your
like your writing regimen are you daily
do you have a daily discipline like
because you need a lot i need to get
more discipline yeah i'm more
disciplined with
preparing for the podcast
okay
but in terms of writing i need to get
more discipline i need to put that in
the schedule and just take some time
just like talk out ideas
i need to do that you're more are you
more vocal i like interviewed mark
norman on here yeah and he said his
whole writing process is he just walks
around the room for an hour talking
through bits are you more vocal you pin
to paper more i can do that i'm
definitely not pen to paper i've never
pen paper um
i i like conversation that's how i write
like if i have a talk with somebody
mm-hmm and we're talking about an idea
that's where it will come out like i'll
be like okay it's what's going on or
something that's funny there's something
there that's good
you know that will be that's the i don't
it's very hard for me to just be like oh
here's a joke
one of my favorite jokes of yours is the
the mexicans stealing our jobs oh yeah
yeah the joke is absolutely
brilliant and so well put together thank
you man i should put that [__] up before
there's no more mexicans here dude
and talking about that joke for just a
second sure did it start with you
hearing maybe in conversation people
saying mexicans are stealing our jobs
and then you just take it to this whole
other level how did you kind of develop
that joke i've always had like a an
affinity um
for mexicans and mexican culture you
know i lived in spain i came back to
california
and i worked in restaurants with these
guys who literally would work
uh
18 hours a day
um
seven days a week six seven days a week
uh i have families here send money back
to their families there and they tell me
these amazing stories of how they got
into america and like
just hearing about
what they're able to do just to
support their families back home i just
had this real i don't know i was just i
just thought they were just such a
special people man
really special people yeah and i would
hear people saying how they're stealing
the jobs that kind of stuff like that it
just didn't sit right to me so it was my
way of kind of like defending
defending these people who i didn't
think were stealing jobs i thought they
were doing the american thing that we've
done for years here which is a new
immigrant class comes and they do the
jobs nobody else wants to do and that's
how it started
but then to actually make it funny
like we're like oh give me your dishes
and all that yeah yeah
yeah it's just uh i don't know why i
thought that i don't even know i forget
how i how this came about man i think
i wonder if it started
you have a lot of good examples in there
i guess you had to go through a lot of
that joke has evolved it's been a long
time like it's a there's been a long i
mean that's real that's joke's been
around a while that was like one of the
first
one of my first jokes it did really well
okay
you know yeah
yeah that was one of the first ones that
did very
you know you have these jokes i'm sure
you recognize it as a stand-up where
you're just like
all right this is this one works like i
can remember the first joke that worked
consistently and then the first joke
that really kind of killed
and uh
yeah
just clicks some just come together yeah
they just come together you know you get
these fights so that was one of them i'm
trying to think exactly what the
what they
oh man i don't know exactly where it
came about that's a bummer that i can't
remember that but yeah it's evolved and
then there's this whole other thing i
don't know if i did the whole thing that
do the apple store the apple and if we
can sell oranges we can sell apple yeah
yeah
just making that connection i mean do
you you just write on stage more like
you just talk about stealing our jobs
and that just kind of came together
piece by piece over time basically okay
i just thought it was kind of like
that's how things happen to me like the
idea of like like i'll think about
something
i'll be honest the one thing that annoys
me about that joke is it's likeable
like the joke the joke is pretty likable
like i think most people have you know
a a little bit of compassion for mexican
immigrants right i don't i tend to
gravitate towards humor that
you have no compassion for definitely
and then you defend it and then i defend
it right so so this is
this is a joke that like
i'm kind of like a good guy on
which is the one thing i don't like
about that being said it's like
something i do believe you know what i
mean i like being a bad guy in every
joke that's so fun but that's what it
comes to it's like you hear somebody say
something they're stealing the jobs or
even like with the grab the [__] thing
and like i'll just ruminate on that i'm
like grabbing a [__] is it wrong to
grab the [__] like how do you grab a
[__] like how do you well how do you
have i ever grabbed a [__]
yeah i've grabbed it matter of fact i've
i've always grabbed was i never asked
for permission to grab [__] i just
grabbed [__] right so like that's where
it goes right yeah you know instead of
just like accepting conventional wisdom
which is all these people think it's
wrong okay i'll think it's wrong
yeah it's impressive that you you did
that joke and you're like but you've
never met a billionaire you had women
clapping yeah yeah that's that i mean
that's just amazing to just flip people
like that it's it was really fun to
watch i'm glad you liked it yeah man it
was it was great to see you work live
and it was great for you to share this
time with me man my brother i really
appreciate your generosity for sure uh
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
oh man they could check out all the
things i'm doing just on on uh
my podcast the brilliant idiots and uh
also
um just twitter and instagram i usually
you know keep posted that's uh andrew
schultz schulz
so yeah
but um yeah man thanks for having me bro
appreciate it and check him out on
sneaky pete too you know
yeah that was a cool couple episodes man
but uh yeah andrew schultz thanks for
being on hot breath man my brother thank
you very much
[Music]
you